- You have media
sources that you thought
were these pristine,
amazing institutions,
like the New York Times
or the Washington Post
or CNN or MSNBC, but
every single day and
every single night
they're running more articles
or running more stories
saying that, oh, the
breaking gun, breaking news.
- [Dave] The walls
are crashing in.
- The walls are crashing in,
and I'd see it every day.
I'd turn on Rachel Maddow
at night and I was like,
holy cow, do people
actually believe this?
And I write actually, you
know, Schumer used to be
a close friend of our family,
and he was going around
the Upper East Side telling
all my parents' friends,
Jared's about to be indicted,
he's gonna go to jail,
we know it for sure,
we have all the facts,
what they did to
collude with Russia.
They were basically
denying an election.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining me
is a former senior adviser
to President Donald J. Trump
and author of the
brand new book,
the New York Times' number
one best selling book.
We're gonna have to talk
about that in just a second.
"Breaking History".
Jared Kushner, good
to see you, my friend.
How's it going?
- Doing great.
Thank you for
having me on, David.
- I am glad to be
sitting here with you.
First off, they put
you at number one in
the New York Times.
I don't think the New York
Times likes you very much,
and they did it.
How does that feel,
because they didn't put me
on there at all
for my last book.
So this is a little
bit of a tug here.
- You know, it is funny
that it's given this height
as a goal to attain, but
I think that is the goal
that all the people who
are authors try to attain,
so it's nice to
have achieved it.
But you try not to give
it too much value as well.
But it was kind of funny.
They wrote a review
that was pretty unhinged
in terms of how they
characterized the book.
And actually once that happened,
the sales of the book
started going up immediately,
and I think it's because
what's in the book
contradicts a lot of what
they wrote about Trump
and his administration
for four years.
And so they obviously didn't
want to see it in existence
or want people to
read a point of view
that differs from theirs.
- They are not big fans
of that, that is for sure.
I do appreciate the fact
that your book matches
our Locals set pretty perfectly.
As you know, I just
got back on the grid.
So you released,
the book came out
the last week of August, right?
So I did not get to
see any of your press
around this or anything.
So I'm going into
this pretty blind,
and when I've mentioned
you on the show,
we've gotten to know each
other a little bit personally
over the last couple of months
since I moved down here.
When I mention you on
the show, I often say
people don't know what
his voice sounds like.
They see him, but
they don't know
what his voice sounds like.
So let's do the
beginning stuff first.
I'm a Long Island guy,
you're a Jersey guy.
We had a similar background,
somewhat similar ages.
Tell people a little
bit of the Jared Kushner
growing up story.
- I thought you were gonna
ask me to sing or something
with that build up.
So no, it's great, and obviously
it's been great having you
and your family down in Florida
now, your extended family.
So basically I grew
up in New Jersey
and had a lot of
different experiences.
I try to write it very
quickly in the book, right?
It's like doing your
obituary in 5,000 pages,
trying to just condense it.
But basically grew
up in a great suburb,
had amazing parents, and
just write about the journey.
My life, I write about
obviously starting businesses
in college and whatnot,
and I write about
how afterwards I was in law
school and business school.
Sorry, I'm not used to
nice questions like that.
- You're freaking out because
I'm not trying to get you.
I'll get you in a second.
- I'm used to the killers
coming at me, so it's too nice.
But basically I write in the
book about my upbringing.
I was in law school at
NYU and business school
after graduating Harvard,
and I was working
at the Manhattan District
Attorney's office.
I thought I'd be a prosecutor.
And then my father got
arrested and I realized
I didn't want to be
a prosecutor anymore.
I kind of saw what
happens when prosecutors
have a lot of political
ambition and unchecked power,
and I didn't think I
could be in that position.
And then I write through what
that experience was like,
how it changed my
view of the world.
I met a lot of people
through that experience.
I went into my
father's business.
It was a real time of problems.
Really through that period,
that three year period
and then the three year period
of the financial downturn,
that was where I
learned a lot of lessons
that really taught me a lot.
And then I write about
how I was very fortunate
when I was in New York to
meet a great beautiful woman
named Ivanka, who we had
an interesting courtship.
She said yes, which
was really great.
I got the permission
from her dad.
- Do you go to the
dad first on that one?
- I actually give a
little bit of this story,
but I didn't really spend
too much time with him
for about the first year that
we were dating on and off.
And then we were getting
serious, and so Ivanka said,
you know, my dad, you've
got to go talk to him,
because if not, he's
gonna start thinking
you're not interested.
And so I reach out to him
and I say, hi Mr. Trump.
This is Jared Kushner.
I'm dating Ivanka.
I'd really like to come over
and spend some time together.
I didn't know what the
hell I was gonna say.
And he says, that's great, why
don't we have lunch tomorrow?
I'm like, oh man, that's tough.
I go over to Trump
Tower, and we have lunch
in the Trump Grill, and
what was funny about him
was he would never
go out for lunch.
So Ivanka was very surprised,
because he would always
have lunch by his desk.
He didn't like to waste
the time of going out.
So we go in Trump
Grill in Trump Tower,
he's got Trump
security guards around.
- Trump napkins, Trump glasses.
- Trump order, Trump
meatloaf, everything.
And I said, look, Ivanka and I,
we're getting more serious now,
and she started a process
of converting to Judaism.
He turns to me and says, well,
why does she have to
convert to Judaism?
Why can't you convert?
And I said actually, that's
a really good question.
Nobody's asked me that question.
But you know, we've
been studying,
and this is how we
feel we want to go.
And he says, that's great.
You know, I've been in New
York real estate all my life.
Everyone thinks I'm Jewish,
all my friends are Jewish.
And from that point,
he was very supportive.
And then he goes into another
thing which was funny,
that I tell in the
book, where he says,
as you know, Ivanka right now,
she's at an amazing
place in her life.
A lot of my friends call,
they all respect her, he says,
but you know, Tom
Brady's a good friend,
and he's been dying
to take her out.
And so I turned to
him and I said, well,
if I was her I'd go
out with Tom Brady.
And he looks at me,
maybe getting my self
deprecating humor,
or maybe it was serious,
and he basically looks
and says, yeah, I know.
So it was good.
- Wow, so you beat out
Tom Brady for Ivanka.
- In his version of events.
Yeah, I don't know.
- It's close enough to
something that sounds right.
Can you just back
up a little bit
and explain a little bit
more about some of the stuff
with your dad and
how that woke you up
and then kind of changed the
course correction for you,
because I think that's
a super interesting
part of the story here.
- Sure, so I write
about this in the book
as condensed as I can,
but basically my father
was a major Democrat donor,
New Jersey's a big
Democrat state.
He was involved in
a family dispute.
It was a business
that he'd built up,
he'd brought his siblings in,
and basically he was
prosecuted for three years.
They couldn't really find much.
But then he did something
maybe a little over-reacting
kind of to get maybe
revenge on them
for causing so much pain to him,
which, you know, human
beings make mistakes.
And he basically sent a
tape of his brother-in-law
who was always having
affairs with a prostitute
and then sent it to his sister
just basically to say screw you.
And then at the time, his
lawyers knew about it.
They didn't think
that it was a crime,
but he didn't know
that his siblings
were then cooperating
witnesses with the government.
So they arrested him.
Chris Christie was the
prosecutor at the time.
He made a big deal of
it, very ambitious.
He ultimately went
on to be governor.
And after that
happened, my father,
I write about the experience.
It was very reflective about it.
He said, look, I sinned
before God, before man.
I made a mistake.
I let my power go to my head,
and I shouldn't have done that.
So he took a plea deal and
went to prison for a year.
And it was very hard.
His company was a big
company at the time,
had about 1,000 employees.
And when he left,
I had to deal with,
I went to his office
five days a week.
We had great professionals
who stepped up
to run the company, but
you have a million people,
the government was
still sending subpoenas,
trying to target people.
It was very chaotic, and I'd
go and visit him every week,
or maybe I'd take a week
off every now and then,
but try to visit him
every week in prison
just to spend the time.
My father and I were very close,
we ran the marathon together,
and he's an amazing person.
So I think you learn a
lot from that experience.
One thing he said
to me was, you know,
life, sometimes
you're at 10,000 feet.
You have to come down to earth
to really understand
what's there.
And so I saw very high in
life, I saw very low in life.
And going through
that experience,
you realize that things
can get taken from you.
Your freedom can
be taken from you,
your wealth can
your clothes can
be taken from you.
And what really matters
is just your friends,
your health, and what you do
and what you make of
the time you have.
And so it was a
fundamentally transformative
period of my life.
And I write about
my reactions after,
and two specific things
that I write about,
number one is after
a couple of days
of spending time with him
and getting that situation
as settled as it was gonna
get, I go back to New York
and got back to my
apartment on Mercer Street,
and I basically just sat on
the floor and I started crying.
I realized that my life
had changed, and I realized
that there was a lot of
things I was angry at.
You're angry at the prosecutor,
you're angry at my
father's siblings
for escalating
something over money,
and then I was angry at
my father to a degree.
I realized that that
just wasn't productive.
And then I really made
a decision to shift
all of my time and effort
towards trying to be helpful,
helpful to my mom,
helpful to my dad,
helpful to my siblings,
helpful to the company.
And that was just a
fundamental choice.
And I think that that's
been something in my life,
whether it was of the
challenges in business
that occurred, or even
my time in government.
Any time there was a
challenge, a lot of people
get very angry or try to
figure out why it happened
or what they could
have done different.
I always would just say,
okay, well, it is what is is.
How do we take the
variables we have
and try to make it
as good as it can be?
And so that was really
a fundamental lesson.
And I think the other
lesson I learned as well
is I finally did my first day
back at the office at the DA.
I would take the six
train down to Canal Street
from Astor Place, and
I was going back up,
and for whatever reason
I just couldn't stand up,
so I just stayed on the
train, and I rode the train
all the way up to
the Bronx and back
for about usually
two to three hours,
and I was just looking at
everyone's faces, right?
You're seeing the people
getting on and off the train.
For whatever reason, in
my mind I was saying,
what's their story,
and I was kind of
making up stories for each one.
I was saying, well, this woman,
maybe she can't find a
way to feed her family,
or maybe this guy's
about to lose his job,
or maybe this woman
just found out
that her mother has cancer.
And so I kind of realized
everyone has problems in life,
and I had my problems,
but everyone has problems.
And so I kind of said, you know,
nobody wants to hear
about your problems.
You've got to just do the best
with what you've got every
day and move forward.
So it was a very
interesting experience.
I met a lot of people in
prison, or within prison.
My father actually,
amazing people,
still friends to this day,
from different backgrounds,
some were bad people,
some were amazing people
who just made mistakes.
And so it was a very
interesting period of life,
and one that obviously
taught me a lot.
- What was it about
the prosecution
that caused you to have that
change and not go that route?
Did you just see corruption?
Did you see an
endless goose chase?
- So I saw, my father,
he was really the leader
of our community.
Anyone who would lose a job,
he would give them a job.
Anytime somebody needed a
surgery and couldn't afford it,
he would pay for it anonymously.
He supported so many people
and did so much good.
When he was sentenced,
he had over 700 letters
that were sent on his behalf.
Each one was more
beautiful than the next,
about stories that even his
family didn't know about.
And what I saw was that
they started investigating,
and then they were
looking for one thing.
And then it just never ends.
Then they keep digging
for more and more,
and there was an accountant
who stole all the documents
who now works for
my father's brother
who turned it over
to the government.
And it just played
out in the press.
It was funny, at the time one
of this friends said to me,
there's an Irish saying
which is tall buildings
attract lightning, and
he was a tall building
and he attracted lightning.
I saw just that prosecutors
have unlimited power,
unlimited resources, and when
they want to dig, they'll dig.
I mean, it was a
company that had
hundreds of millions of
dollars of revenue at the time,
and ultimately they
were saying, okay,
you should have categorized
something this way
instead of this way for a
couple of hundred thousand,
and that was what
he kind of pled to.
And that's pretty subjective,
and usually something
that's done civilly
as opposed to criminally.
So I just saw that Christie
wanted to get my father,
he was a big trophy
politically for him,
and he was just
absolutely relentless.
But again, my father,
under so much pressure,
allowed his emotions to
get the better of him
and made a mistake as well,
which was a lesson for me
going through all
the investigations
that we ultimately went
through as well in Washington,
which was if you
have good facts,
you just have to be
tight, be tight, be tight.
And again, people saw
I didn't talk much.
They saw me accused of
all kinds of things,
but I tried to just be
tight, be tight, be tight,
just to know that I didn't think
my enemies could defeat me,
but I knew that I was
capable of defeating myself
by making a mistake, and I
didn't want that to happen.
- Yeah, it's funny
you turned it to that
because as you were saying
that, I was thinking,
boy, this sort of endless chase
and this power that they
have to keep going and going,
that does sound awfully familiar
to some things
happening these days.
So obviously it's not
what the book's about,
but just to knock out a
little bit of current events
kind of quickly,
when you're seeing
what's happening right now,
the raid and all this stuff,
does it ring very
familiar to you?
Like oh, we just
kind of have power
and we can exercise that power,
and then we'll figure
out if he did something.
A little bit like that?
- A thousand percent.
You saw this with Trump.
And again, I write
about in the book
what it's like to be in
the middle of that storm
and being accused of treason
and having to spend two years.
At some point you're saying,
maybe I'm the one who's crazy,
because I know I didn't
collude with Russia.
I mean, most days I
couldn't collude with Trump
on the campaign, or the
handful of people we had.
It was a ragtag campaign,
and I write about
how we pulled it
together and did that.
But then you go to Washington.
You have media sources
that you thought
were these pristine,
amazing institutions
like the New York Times
or the Washington Post
or CNN or MSNBC.
But every single day
and every single night,
they're running more articles
or running more stories
saying that the breaking
gun, breaking news.
- [Dave] The walls
are crashing in.
- The walls are crashing in.
And I'd see it every day.
I'd turn on Rachel Maddow
at night, and I was like,
holy cow, do people
actually believe this?
And I write actually
Schumer used to be
a close friend of our family,
and he was going around
the Upper East Side telling
all my parents' friends,
Jared's about to be indicted,
he's gonna go to jail,
we know it for sure,
we have all the facts,
what they did to
collude with Russia.
They were basically
denying an election.
But anyway, that
was definitely it.
And I see it with Trump now,
where they tried one thing,
it failed, they tried the
next thing, it failed.
And then he leaves office.
And then they impeach him
after he leaves office.
And then now he's being looked
at by the Attorney General,
even though there was
no money lost at all,
but they're saying maybe
his financial statements
were either high or
low or whatever it is.
Then they run these
primetime hearings
basically to say what
a bad person he was.
And then they raid his home.
And so I do have
a lot of feelings
that prosecutors left unchecked
with political ambitions,
and that's why one of
the issues I write about
in the book too is how,
because of my experiences,
I spearheaded an effort
that President Trump
ultimately endorsed
and got behind
to bring criminal
justice reform.
And I do think that
his being so persecuted
while he was in Washington
opened his heart to appreciate
how unfair prosecutors can be.
What bothers me a lot is
that all of the people
who are my allies from the left
against big government overreach
and how unfair
prosecutors can be,
they were amazing
advocates, they believe it,
but when it happens
to Trump, it's okay.
And so the moral lines
are a little bit,
they have, I guess,
footnotes to it.
- I think that's pretty
much the definition
of Trump Derangement Syndrome,
these people that have
this set of beliefs,
but when it comes to Trump,
those beliefs kind
of just don't exist.
So going forward a little bit,
before you got
fully into politics,
so now you and
Ivanka are married,
Donald signed off
on it obviously.
And you're living a
life in New York City
that's not political,
particularly, right?
And then the call comes in.
Okay, he's gonna do this thing.
Did you immediately think
that you could be part of it
or had value to add or that
Ivanka wanted to be part of it
or were you worried, et cetera?
- So we didn't know, I
know this may sound weird,
but I would imagine most
families sit around and say,
what should we do?
This is a big decision.
I write about we were
having lunch with Donald
for I think it was his birthday,
and he says to the kids,
he says, okay guys, I'm
announcing this week
and everything's
gonna be different.
And with him, there's
always something,
and he'd been flirting
with it for a long time.
He'd asked Ivanka to
write a speech for him.
And actually one
thing that was funny,
she took him to go
see Rupert Murdoch,
because she said, look,
if you're running,
you've got to go sit with him.
And Rupert says, you're not
running, you're not gonna do it.
And Donald left and he says,
why was he so dismissive?
And Ivanka says, look Dad,
you asked me to introduce you
when you give your speech.
I'm still not sure
you're gonna announce.
And she says, look, by the way,
if you make me write this
speech and get ready,
and I give this speech and
you get up there and say,
just kidding, I'll
be pretty mad at you.
And so he kind of went into it.
And then we also,
let's see what happens.
And the first month
was just crazy.
I mean, somebody tweeted
which I saw, which was funny,
where they said the last
slow news day we had
was June 15th, 2015, the
day before he announced.
- The day before the escalator.
- And he got up there.
The month after for
Ivanka was really consumed
with putting out all the fires.
I think Trump lost
about $30 million
in just annual contracts
that were coming in
with different vendors,
and her and her brothers
were dealing with that.
And I didn't really get involved
until I guess it was later on.
Donald said, come
with me to a rally.
And I said, do you know what?
Let me see this.
Everyone in my social
circle in New York
was saying this is a
joke, he's gonna lose.
But every time that happened,
he kept going up more
and more in the polls.
And so I thought we were
in a very worldly circle,
we're with the
heads of the banks,
the heads of the
fashion industry,
the heads of the technology,
the heads of the media.
And I said, let me just go
see things with my own eyes.
So I traveled with him
to Springfield, Illinois.
We fly out in his big
757 Trump Force One jet.
We're going out there,
and he's just bullshitting
like he does, talking about
the grandkids and football.
And we walk out, and I have
no idea what to expect.
We get into a car, go
to a convention center.
We walk in, the gentleman
greets him and says,
welcome Mr. Trump.
Congratulations.
You just broke the record
for this convention center.
And he says, well,
who's the record?
And he says, well, it was
Elton John 36 years ago.
And he turns to me and he says,
see, and I don't
even have a guitar.
So we went in there.
I also was surprised too.
I saw him shaking everyone's
hand, and he was a germophobe
before it was popular
to be a germophobe.
And so he was shaking
everyone's hand,
really engaging with
everyone he saw,
trying to get
information from them.
And he gets up on
stage for about an hour
and just talks with
no notes or anything.
And there's one
particular moment,
he was talking about trade,
where he was saying things
that were contrary
to what my friends
in the Upper East Side thought.
But he gets up
there and he says,
we're gonna end common core
and we're gonna send it
to the states, and
the crowd went wild.
And keep in mind,
the crowd was not
what CNN told you
what it was gonna be.
They made it seem like it
was Ku Klux Klan or whatever.
It was old, young, white,
Black, male, female,
and it just felt like
it was real Americans
who felt like the government
had stopped representing them.
And so a few weeks earlier
I had been at a charity gala
in New York for the
Robin Hood Foundation,
which is one of these great
groups that does amazing work.
And the president of it
gets up there and says
the way we are gonna create
equality in this country
and save our country is
by promoting common core,
and what everyone has to
do is call their senators,
call their Congressman.
This is the policy.
This is it.
This is gonna change.
I was like, okay, I guess
common core is good.
I mean, what did I know?
I was doing real
estate and technology.
I wasn't deep in the policies.
So it kind of made me think,
wait, I thought all
these worldly people
knew what they
were talking about.
Why do these people feel
so differently to them?
And so all it did was
really start my exploration
through the process.
- What did you consider yourself
politically at that point,
if you were sort of
having your own wake up
relative to some of this stuff?
Did you consider yourself
like a New York liberal,
like I was an Upper West Side
liberal, I was for many years.
I'm obviously not
anymore, but did you?
- I wouldn't say that.
When I was Harvard, I was
probably much more liberal.
That's what you're taught.
You take Ec 10 with
Marty Feldstein,
and you have certain views
of how the world works.
I started off doing
kind of social studies,
so it was reading a lot of
the political theorists.
But through the newspaper,
we endorsed Obama in 2008.
And then in 2012,
we endorsed Romney,
because I thought that Obama's
policies were very divisive
and I thought that
he was terrible with
his Middle East work
especially how he was going
to try to do a deal with Iran,
and I felt like he
was really weakening
the U.S. Israel relationship,
which I didn't like.
And so I endorsed him.
And I was very close with
Mike Bloomberg at the time.
I thought he represented,
he was probably
the best embodiment of
my political package.
So I was registered
as an independent,
but probably at that
point very centrist.
But like I said, it
was kind of this deep.
And I learned too, most
people are actually this deep.
One of the cool
things about the book
is I take people
through my journey
as somebody who was
from that echo chamber
and then went and
explored the country.
Most people don't get to meet
people who disagree with them
and don't engage with them.
And I got to speak
with so many people,
but I did it with an open mind
because I was having to
write speeches at the time
for Donald on the campaign
that were representing
his points of view,
which were points of view
that were different
than what I thought
was the right point
of view to have.
So in doing that, I was
exploring these things,
researching these things,
and it opened my eyes
to the fact there's
a lot more nuance
to a lot of these policies.
- So then the
campaign's starting.
I've talked to Don
Junior about this
publicly on this
show, and privately.
He was telling me
how so many people
that were lifelong
friends of his
suddenly deserted him and
just all of that nonsense.
So now you and
Ivanka are intimately
involved in this thing,
and then he wins.
Now you're going to DC.
I mean, first off,
did you have just
a whole bunch of friends
that shed you immediately,
and how insane was
just getting to DC
and then seeing
what that was like?
- So believe it
or not, we didn't,
and I think that
what happened was
is I think through my
father's experience,
I was very selective
in who I let in.
So Ivanka and I have a
very close relationship,
and a lot of our time
in New York was spent
just the two of us.
If we had to choose between
going to a dinner party
or being with us,
we would be with us,
and we would always love
doing different adventures,
going on dates, trying
new restaurants,
seeing new neighborhoods.
And then as we started
building a family,
that was a priority
for us as well.
We'd had a ton of
acquaintances from New York,
but the people who
are our real friends
were people who we thought
were very quality people
who we got things
out of, and I think
who got things out of us.
And those people were all
people mostly on the left
of the political spectrum.
Again, I probably had like
one conservative friend
that I could think of from
before this experience.
But everyone was very
respectful and very open
of what we were doing,
and recognized that again,
it wasn't Ivanka and I
who were giving speeches
or making policies.
It was her father,
and she was doing
what a devoted
daughter would do.
But for me, I was
much more open-minded,
much more studying the policies.
I think for Ivanka,
she basically said,
okay, if this is the
situation that's happening,
she had a mission-driven
business at the time,
which there were issues
she was advocating for.
She said, well, if I can
use this as a platform
to elevate the issues
she cared about,
like paid family
leave and child care,
she says, well, I think
it's kind of irresponsible
not to do that.
So she gave a speech at the
RNC introducing her father,
and all the things on the
internet after were saying
did she think she was at
the Democratic convention,
because they were
not traditionally
Republican policies.
- And that her dad used to
be loved by the Democrats.
I mean, there's no
shortage of pictures
with all those people when
they used to love him,
and he was donating
to some of them.
- Yeah, being in
New York, and again,
he was part of pop culture.
Yeah, but the short
answer is that our friends
were really strong
and really still are.
What I found is that when we
decided to go to Washington,
and I write about kind of
how we made that decision,
because it wasn't
like we were thinking,
okay, he's gonna win and
then this is gonna happen.
The whole campaign was like,
let's get to goal
line plus an inch.
Who the hell knows how
this is gonna work out?
- But you do talk about that.
You kind of thought
it was gonna happen
the whole time, right?
- Again, logically it felt like
he should be able to do it.
All the math, and I can go
into a whole thing on polling.
But from what I saw,
the polling all seemed
like it was not scientific.
So if you look at all
the public polling
that predicted he was
gonna lose, I was shocked
by how many people
just followed it.
But polling is basically
you call 500 people
and they say yes or no, and
then you have to do something
called a weighting, and
weighting is basically you say,
okay, if we called 100
Democrats and 100 Republicans,
how many people do you
think are gonna vote,
and then you kind of
recalculate the results
in order to do that.
So what happened in Brexit,
right, before Trump won,
was the polling
was off massively.
Now, it predicted
the amount of people
who said stay pretty accurately,
but it was off by about
three million votes
for the people who
predicted to leave.
And as we researched
why that was,
I was reading all
the info on it,
it basically said that
they just under counted
low propensity voters.
So with Trump, all
the media was using
basically the Obama/Romney
turnout model,
and I was like, I don't
think that'd indicative.
Obama had a different
electricity that
Hillary didn't have,
and Trump had a
different electricity
that Romney didn't have.
So it felt like it
should be different,
and then when I'd look
at, we built a data file
of about 10 million
people who were showing up
at Trump rallies, and a
big percentage of them
were low propensity voters.
And so basically every
time we'd do a sample,
which we re-engineered
the polling,
we basically ran it through
two different models.
One was the media model, which
showed we were gonna lose,
and one was our model, which
showed we were gonna win.
And so I just, again, Romney
went into election night
thinking they were
gonna win, I was told,
and then were disappointed.
So I never allowed myself
to believe our data
because I'd never
done it before.
But that was what I believed
was more logical as an outcome,
but we didn't think about
what would come next.
Sorry for such a long thing.
- No, no, so speaking
of what came next,
so now you get there, now you're
working for the President.
The media's not that
happy, CNN, New York Times,
okay, all that stuff.
But you guys actually were
accomplishing an awful lot
pretty much from the get
go, considering you had
nobody willing to work with you.
- Yeah, so it was a wild thing.
The first year, in
writing the book
I went through the first
year, and it brought back
a lot of memories that actually
were really painful for me,
because A, we get to Washington.
So we make the decision
to, and it wasn't like
should we stay in New
York and live our lives
or should we go to Washington?
It was like, okay,
he is now gonna be
the President of
the United States.
Our former lives as we knew
it don't exist anymore.
And then you see you have
an opportunity to serve
in government and try
to make an impact,
and I built more confidence
based on the fact
that on the campaign I was able
to achieve certain successes
and things that experienced
political people told me
was the wrong way to do it,
but then I did it that way
and it ended up working.
And so I said, well,
let's give it a shot
and let's try to help him.
Again, he'd never been a
mayor, never been a governor.
He was running a
family business,
he was used to
working with family,
his campaign was
a family campaign.
And so we said let's
go give it a shot
and really try to see if
we could help him implement
the policies that we believe in
and try to do things
that we believe are good.
So Ivanka gave up her business
to then focus on her mission.
I went in, and we had no
idea what a brutal world
Washington was gonna be.
So whether it was the
attacks from the media,
whether it was
the investigation.
Within three months I have
people leaking on me like crazy
from inside the White House.
You'd talk to yourself
and it would be
in the Washington Post.
- Wait, can you just
talk a little bit more
about what that's like,
the leak situation?
How is it possible, because
everyone's always talking
about the leaks, they
were talking about it
an awful lot with
Trump, but it happens
in every administration.
Did you feel like, oh, here's
10 people in this room,
in this meeting, six of
them might be the one.
How do you manage some of
that stuff as an adviser?
Or do you pull him aside
and say, Mr. President,
maybe don't, or Dad-in-law,
or whatever you call him,
Don, do you maybe don't
say everything you think
off the cuff in
front of everybody
because we have this problem?
- So I think I learned, and
I think he learned as well.
You know, one of the funny
jokes somebody told me
was they said in Washington,
if you want to keep a secret
between three people, two
of them have to be dead.
But it wasn't quite that bad.
I think it was a function
of in the beginning
I felt very, very helpless.
Like I said, I'd think something
and it would leak to
the Washington Post.
It was so bad, and I
think with him too.
So a couple of things.
Again, I write about
how I adjusted and said,
okay, the game is the game.
It's been here long before me,
it's gonna be here
long after me.
You have a chance
to be in the game.
If you are in the game, you
can get good things done,
but you have to get
better at the game.
And so certain things like
when I would give my opinion
to Donald, especially when
I would disagree with him,
I would always do it one on one.
I would never say my opinion
in front of other people.
Or I would say something
that I didn't think
would be salacious, but when
I wanted to strongly disagree,
I would always do it privately
because you never wanted to
read about that in the press
because that would, I
never wanted division
to show between us
because he always gave me
the opportunity to
voice my opinion,
and sometimes he would
listen, sometimes he wouldn't.
Again, I was an adviser.
And some things, quite frankly,
I had more conviction on,
some things I had
less conviction on.
And often when he would
ask me, I would say,
look, I'm not an expert on
it, let me find somebody
who I think is,
and bring them in
to give you that point of view.
So that was probably number one.
And then when it came to
just dealing with people,
you learn very quickly who
was leaking to which places.
We just had so many of
them who were scumbags
who were doing that.
- But were they all your
guys, do you know what I mean,
or were they sort
of deep state people
that were all
there all the time?
- No, no, no.
A lot of them were
the people coming in.
Look, I mean we didn't have
a lot of people, right?
The campaign was ragtag.
We had to staff up quickly.
We were making a
lot of decisions,
putting different
people together,
and yeah, you just have people.
And then the more
people get insecure,
the more it's an environment
that kind of
encourages more of it.
So it's a very, very complicated
situation to work in.
But like I said, I figured out
how to adjust, I got tighter,
and then ultimately over
time, like towards the end,
we announce a peace deal
which we'll talk about later,
and nobody knows about it.
So I learned how to find the
people who you could work with
to keep things quiet, but
it just took me some time.
Like when you work in
real estate or technology,
nobody's out there
leaking to the press.
And everyone's aligned
for the same mission too.
So it's just a different game
and you just have to learn
to adjust to the game.
- Right, so all right, let's
jump over to the peace process.
So now things are happening,
you're a couple of years in.
You were working on this
from day one basically?
Really, was it from
day one you said
this is gonna be something
I'm gonna get on?
Did he want you on that?
Was this something that
you just brought to him?
- So the way I found out
about it was I get a call
from the woman who
did public relations
for our real estate business.
And at the time Ivanka
and I were still thinking
will we go to Washington or not?
And she calls and says, the
New York Times just called
and said you and Ivanka have
decided to go to Washington,
that you're working
on Middle East peace.
And I said, that's not true.
I said that we haven't
made a decision.
She says, well, their source
is your father-in-law.
I said, okay.
So he went there for I guess
an editorial board meeting,
and they asked him.
He said, ah, Jared's
great, he's gonna come
and he's gonna work
on Middle East peace.
- Oh, that's hilarious.
- I don't know if
he meant it or not,
but the next day they're
going, who is Jared Kushner?
What the hell does he know
about the Middle East?
By the way, they were right,
I didn't know anything.
Maybe it was the last
time they were right.
But then after the
first couple of months,
I said, okay, this is
something I was tasked with,
let me start exploring.
So Jason Greenblatt came in
with me, and Avi Berkowitz.
We started just researching
what had been done before us.
What I did in the first
year was I just tried
to understand everyone's
perspective on the file.
So my biggest deficit
was that I didn't have
any diplomatic experience,
but my biggest advantage
was that I didn't have
any diplomatic experience.
So I came in, and I
give one example in here
where I'm meeting with
the ruler of the UAE,
who's thought to be the
most strategic thinker
in the region.
He's somebody who's
been there a while.
He just became the
president of the country.
And he's a guy, Mohamed bin
Zayed, who's really a giant.
And I'm meeting with him
after about six months
and I take him through
some of the thoughts
as to how I want to approach it,
and I really was asking
him a ton of questions.
And he says, I think you're
gonna make peace here.
Why do you say that?
He says, well, the
U.S. usually sends
one of three types
of people to see me.
The first types
are people who come
and fall asleep in meetings.
The second are people who come
and they basically
read me talking points
and have no ability to
have a conversation.
The third are senior
level people who come
and basically try to
convince me to do things
that are against my interests.
He says you're the first person
who's ever come to see me
from the U.S. who's
asking questions.
And my fundamental
question was very simple,
which is the U.S.
has a ton of power.
What would you do
if you were us?
What's the end state
that's achievable here,
and what levers would you
play with if you were us
in order to try to
achieve that end state?
And it took him a couple of
times of me asking that question
to actually understand
that I was seeking
honest feedback on the question.
But that was how I
started with everyone,
trying to understand,
get their point of view
on what needed to be
done, knowing that
American foreign
policy, and this is not
a knock on Democrats,
it's a knock on Democrats
and Republicans,
basically screwed up
the entire Middle East.
If you take it from allowing,
even just from the fall
of the shaw in Iran to
the revolution in '79,
and then you go into
obviously allowing al Qaeda
to have harbor, and then
the attacks on the U.S.
and then getting us
into a war in Iraq
and a war in Afghanistan,
and then you have
disbanding the army.
It goes on and on.
Then you have ISIS has a
caliphate the size of Ohio,
they're beheading journalists,
they're killing Christians.
You have them radicalizing
people online,
the San Bernardino shooting,
the Pulse Night Club shooting.
Syria's in a civil war, half
a million people are killed.
I mean, U.S. policy in
that region for decades
was absolutely awful.
And part of it, I guess
maybe Trump was saying
it can't get any worse,
so give Jared a try.
But we thought about
it in a different way,
and really worked hard.
I write about kind of my
journey trying to understand it
for what it was at the time,
instead of being romanced
by the old notions.
And then the more I would talk
to the people who'd done it,
they would explain well, this
is what you have to look at,
this is what you have to do.
I was like, that makes
absolutely no sense to me.
And I was like, okay,
if I'm gonna fail,
at least I'll fail in an
original way in doing something
that I think is logical,
and I was creamed.
I mean, the New York
Times would kill me,
all the experts on CNN,
they would write articles
saying that everything
I was doing was wrong
and stupid and reckless
and gonna cause wars.
- Well, even as the
announcements were coming out,
as the deals were coming
out, they were saying
why these are bad deals.
And it's like, wait, I
thought that we all wanted
Middle East peace.
Wasn't that one thing?
There's a short list of
things we all agree on.
That used to be one thing
that we all kind of want.
So did you find that
a lot of the countries
actually were quite willing
once you made that initial,
once you flipped the
script on them, in essence?
- So in some ways,
the entrenchment there
was just as bad as the
entrenchment at home.
So you think about
all these critics,
and what you have in Washington
is this class of people
who are basically careerists,
going in and out of Washington,
and then you have the
same people who are
writing about them
are from the think tanks or
the media, and they're also.
So it's like the same class.
- I believe this is
what we call the swamp.
Is this the swamp?
- Yeah, and they're all vested
in not being proven wrong.
So they'd rather you also fail
than you be proven
right and do it.
And the whole notion
of the Trump presidency
was bringing people who are
outsiders to Washington,
who are results driven.
Again, politicians are about
process and talking points.
Businessmen are about results.
And so we come in
with a fundamentally
different approach,
and that's the theme in my book
that happens time and
time again, right?
There's two basic
crosscurrents in the book.
One is what is was like to
be under endless attack,
from a Russia investigation,
an impeachment
about trying to look into
corruption in Ukraine,
all the media attacks,
and that's one current.
I call that the waves.
And then you have kind
of under the water
where it's nice and calm,
which is how did all
these policies get done?
How do we get trade deals done?
How do we get peace deals done?
How do we get deals
with Congress done?
How do we get criminal
justice reform done?
And so I really try to put
those two things together.
But that complacency
was the same thing
that I found in the Middle East,
in the sense that
everyone thought
that there were limitations
to what they could do.
And what I found is
all these barriers
are usually in people's minds.
And in the region, everyone
thought it was fixed
and that if there were
certain things you did,
it was just unsolvable,
and you had to go
and solve it the same
way that people before
had tried to solve
it and failed,
or else it's gonna
be World War III.
And I take people
through, again,
I take them into
the situation room
and really try to give
them the intensity
of what it was like to make
some of the first decisions.
So Trump making the
decision to move the embassy
to Jerusalem, his Secretary
of State was against it,
Secretary of Defense
was against it.
The intel community comes
out with an assessment
saying that if he does it,
it could be World War III
and the world's gonna explode.
- Even though every
president for what.
- Had said they
were gonna do it.
- For decades before.
- But then they
all got scared away
by the conventional
thinking that happened.
And what Trump did,
again, a businessman,
you think about,
okay, that's a risk,
how do I assess the risk,
and then how do I
mitigate the risk.
And I talk about how
we assessed the risk,
how we mitigated the risk,
and how we pushed
forward to do it.
And at the end of the
day at that point,
he'd gotten closer with
the Arab countries.
He said, look, you
can't cherry pick
your relationship with America.
Iran's your biggest threat.
I'm gonna work with you on that
because I agree
with you on that.
That's in our common interests.
But don't mess around on the
things that I want to do.
Israel's a sovereign country.
They have a right to
determine their capital.
And America's a
sovereign country,
and we have the right to
recognize the decision
of another sovereign country,
and that's what I'm doing,
and I'm not gonna
ask your opinion.
Again, it was very, very
intense because people showed.
But Trump makes the
decision, and I really use
some funny stories about
kind of the back and forth
and the high stakes of it,
but he makes a decision.
And then we worked
hard to mitigate.
And then what happens is the
next morning the sun rises,
and the next evening the sun
sets and the world moves on.
Same thing with getting
out of the Iran deal.
People warned him
that if you do this,
you're gonna have World War
II, everything's gonna blow up.
He makes a decision, the
next morning the sun rises,
the next evening the sun sets.
And he figured out
ways to maneuver.
And so all of a sudden,
everything that seemed
so fixed to people
all of a sudden
was becoming a little bit
more of a fluid situation.
And so the big obstacle
was the Israelis
and the Palestinians.
Again, as I looked
at that issue,
and I go through
this in the book,
that seemed to me
like a fake situation.
It'd been one of
these manufactured
situations for years,
and there was just so much
assymetry and incentives.
The Palestinian leadership
was getting rich.
I mean, Bibi Netanyahu,
who runs a military
and economic superpower in
Israel, would fly to Israel,
he'd fly in an El
Al commercial jet.
Abbas, who I'm sitting with
him in a meeting like we are,
he wants a cigarette, he puts
a cigarette in his mouth,
somebody comes over and lights
it for him like he's a king,
and then he flies to Washington
in a $60 million BBJ,
you know what I mean?
It's like the whole
thing was he was rich,
his family was rich,
everybody was doing great,
but the Palestinian people
weren't getting the love.
So we exposed kind of what
a bunch of crap that was
and how, again, the goal
of a leader should be to,
number one, provide
security for their people,
number two, to provide
economic opportunities
so people can have
a better life.
Security, he did
as much for himself
as he did for the people,
and I have some examples
in the book of ways
that we tested,
and he kind of was bluffing,
and then we'd call his bluff
and he backs off very weakly.
And then we also have
situations in there
with economics, where we expose
that he wasn't really
trying to do that.
So that was kind of
what we have in there,
and that also allowed the
leaders to think differently
than they did before.
- How much more do you think
you could have got done
had there been four more years?
Were dominoes really
ready to fall?
I remember right before the
election, people kept saying,
oh no, there's six
more deals in place
and there's all
this other stuff.
- We wouldn't have even
needed four more years.
We would have needed
six more months.
And again, I outlined this all
for the incoming administration.
So the last deal
that we got done,
and it was a high wire deal,
and I have some very crazy
moments of this in my book,
was after we get
UAE and Bahrain,
you have Sudan and
Morocco, Sudan goes.
Then Morocco we get in
the lame duck period,
which people were surprised,
and we were trying
to get Saudi to go,
but we couldn't
get Saudi or Qatar
until the rift was
resolved between them.
So I'd been working on that
for about three months,
and we had amazing breakthroughs
in a very intense
negotiation, and now, again,
literally on the
tarmac to take off,
and the deal dies, and
it dies several times.
These are complicated
situations.
So that one we got done Jan 5th,
which I think opened it
up for the administration.
I laid out for them a road map.
We were close with
Mauritania, I felt.
I think Saudi was very doable.
I think now it's a
question of when, not if.
But it needs U.S. leadership
to make it happen.
And so what I basically said
to the incoming administration
is look, congratulations,
you guys are gonna get
all these deals done.
We just were running
out of clock.
But just don't run to Iran.
If you run to Iran, you're
gonna upset everything.
We have Iran weaker
than they've ever been.
Our policy's working.
Just tell Iran you're too busy
working with climate change
and COVID and all this
stuff you're focused on,
and wait for them
to come to you.
What I would do is go
to Saudi Arabia and say,
look, we want you to
do a deal with Israel.
We'll wait six months,
we'll wait a year.
Let's work on a plan together.
I know we said some bad
stuff in the campaign.
You've been a country
that's worked with America
for 80 years, you've been a
great ally in many regards.
What's it gonna take
to get that to happen
so we can finally
end, once and for all,
the Arab Israeli conflict?
And they nodded and then
did absolutely nothing
according to that.
- Did you literally
hand them a packet?
Did you hand them, this
is what's got to happen?
- I didn't write a memo,
but I sat down twice
with the incoming
national security adviser
and basically outlined.
I said look, this
is where we are.
I was giving full transparency
into the discussions.
I fundamentally believe it
could have happened very quickly
had they taken the policy.
But again, they ran to Iran,
got down on their knees,
started begging them.
Trump used to always say
Iran's never won a war,
but never lost a negotiation.
And what they did was terrible.
Then they started kind
of brow-beating Saudi
which made them say, okay,
there's other countries
in the world too.
Then they're running
over to China.
They alienated a lot
of the people there.
Look, I think their recent
policy has shifted back.
They went to Saudi Arabia.
What they did with
UAE, they had missiles
shot at their airport
from the Houthis in Yemen,
so we actually designated the
Houthis a terror organization
because they were firing
missiles into two of our allies
in Saudi Arabia and
UAE and chanting
insignificant statements
like death to America,
death to Israel.
And the first thing the
Biden administration does
when they come in is they
undesignate them as terrorists.
And then they fire
missiles into UAE
that land at their airport.
That's like the nerve
center of commerce,
and the U.S. doesn't call,
they're not restocking
their weapons.
It was a very, very tense time.
So I think right now,
to give them credit,
I think they are understanding
that maybe they didn't
handle it as well
as they could have
in the beginning,
and it does feel, just
from what I'm seeing,
I'm an outsider now, from the
inside they're trying harder,
and I still think that these
deals are very gettable
if they focus on it
in the right way.
- Yeah, do you think
part of the problem is
they don't want to do
anything because it'll feel
like it's just an extension
of what you guys did,
and they sort of want to
erase everything, right?
They don't want them referred
to as the Abraham Accords.
- No, this is one thing
they've come around on,
and actually they participate
in some of the events
we've done to try to
promote the Abraham Accords.
It took them a year, right?
The first year they wouldn't
call it by its name,
but I think that that
was high level people.
I think a lot of the career
folks in the State Department,
they were amazingly
helpful in getting
the Abraham Accords
done and implemented.
And I think even dealing
with Brett McGurk,
he was very supportive.
So I think there are
a lot of people there
who want to see it happen,
and I think with the right
prioritization it can.
I just, again, I don't
know if these guys
have the right ability
to do the negotiation.
Again, they're career
politicians, right?
They're diplomats.
We were the anti-diplomats
in the sense
that we basically came
in and we sat down
and we figured out
how to make deals.
We got six peace deals done,
we got major trade deals done.
And again, I write
about how we did it,
which again, every
single thing in this book
that ended up being effective
towards getting deals done
are things that I
got criticized for
in the pages of the New York
Times and the Washington Post.
- Of course, of course.
So let's talk a little bit
about the COVID situation
and then sort of how
policy worked around that,
because one of the things
that kind of blew me away
the entire time was
that the same people
who every day were calling
Donald Trump Hitler
and all the worst
things in the world,
he's a dictator,
blah, blah, blah,
they were the same
people who wanted him
to have all the federal power
to do whatever he wanted,
because very early
on he was like,
let's leave it to the states
and let them figure it out.
You talk a little bit
about some of the tensions
with Fauci and all that.
How crazy was
that, to advise him
in this sort of unknown moment?
- So that was by far one
of the scariest moments
you could ever have, right?
And again, this was
after three years,
and by the way,
hypocrisy, I figured out,
is not a new thing in
Washington after like day three.
It didn't take me
after three years.
But that was by
far the scariest.
We had things really moving.
Again, our economy was roaring,
we had great people in
place, we had plans,
we were building
for a second term.
Then COVID comes out of nowhere
and really hit the world
like a ton of bricks.
And I write about in
the book my experience
getting pulled in, again,
not as a medical expert,
but just as somebody
to help operationally
who knew how to move the
levers of government.
Vice President Pence, who
I worked very closely with,
asked me to come in and help him
execute with certain things,
like scale testing and whatnot.
But it was very interesting.
So you're making a
lot of decisions.
The media was the first thing
they got Trump on, right,
because if he was more careful,
then he was killing jobs.
If he was opening the economy,
he was killing people.
So CNN kept those tickers
up, depending on the day,
and they were loving the fact
that they could
just bludgeon him.
And you could
always find a nurse
who was afraid they were
gonna run out of stuff.
We were playing whack-a-mole.
I mean, I had stories
that I write about
where I'd see a nurse on CNN
complaining they don't
have masks at a hospital.
I'd get on the phone with
the head of the hospital
and say, what do you need?
We'll get it to you.
And we made sure
all these shortages
that everyone was fearing were
gonna happen did not happen,
and a lot of it was because we
thought like business people,
not like bureaucrats, right?
So I tell stories about how
we find all these masks,
we figure out how to
do DPAs to get them.
In order to get them over,
we don't have enough planes
as the U.S., so I
call Fred Smith,
I call David Abney
from UPS and Fed Ex,
and I say, look, we
need your planes.
And they're like,
they're your air force.
Take them, anything you do.
And even David Abney
only months later,
I've never seen anything
like it in my career,
as quickly as I could
land planes in Asia,
you had them filled with
masks and sent back.
We were under a week away
from running out of supplies
in this country, and again,
Trump thought out of the box.
He empowered business
people to do it
and got a lot of things done.
And ultimately the
biggest test of that
was Operation Warp Speed, right?
So even Fauci said Trump
is over-exaggerating.
It's gonna be at least
a year and a half
until we get a working vaccine.
And so we got the
bureaucracy out of the way,
we brought in the private
sector, brought in the military.
Each thing, and this
is one of the things
I think readers have really
like about the book so far,
is that I'm pretty honest
about mistakes that I made
and things that I
could have done better,
but I show from all these things
how I learned from these
experiences that enabled us.
So the lessons we learned
on scaling testing
was that I always say
to solve a problem,
there's three things you need.
You need imagination, you need
money, and you need gravity.
Those three are
basically the catch alls
of the categories you need.
For testing, we had, I
think, a really good plan,
so the imagination check.
You're the federal
government, you print money,
so we had endless cash,
that wasn't our issue.
But we just couldn't
produce q-tips,
basically swabs for people.
We're about to launch 400 sites,
and they come to
us and say, sorry,
we only have 1.2 million
swabs in the country.
So I'm like, man, and
I started learning
the lowest cost item
was gonna become
our biggest bottleneck.
And that was just
a gravity issue,
so we worked that through.
That was actually one of
our issues with Fauci,
because he goes on
television and he says,
oh, testing, we're
just not there yet,
instead of saying like, dude,
you are in charge of
infectious diseases.
You didn't tell us that we
didn't have enough supplies
in case one came, that you're
sitting on the task force
every day, you've given
us no additional ideas
for how to do this better.
If you're on TV,
explain we have a plan,
we're doing this as fast as
we can, we're going fast.
Instead it was like
are you a sportscaster
or are you a member
of the task force?
- So what do you make of him,
or what did you
make of him then,
and is that different than now?
- I'll get to that in a
sec, but just to finish
what I was saying is that
ultimately those lessons
we learned from Warp Speed,
which is that we did
everything right early,
and that enabled
us to be successful
and ramp up the
manufacturing simultaneously.
And I give some lessons on that.
With him, I think
that to make it for,
first of all, nobody should
be in a job for 50 years,
especially not in
a government job.
I think he was an
excellent politician
in terms of his ability
to be a survivor,
but I think he also
embraced a lot of the,
people would always
build these people up
as a counter to Trump.
Like take Michael Avenatti,
who is now, I think, in prison.
The media made him a hero
because he was against Trump.
So the media would create
these false heroes,
and I think with Fauci,
they elevated him
like they elevated
20 people before.
And I think he embraced it,
and I think he liked it,
and I think that
that led to a lot of,
it wasn't about
service, and it led to
a lot of misinformation
and confusion
that didn't have to be the case.
And so, again, I
give one great scene
where Trump is fighting
with him saying,
Doc, I'm not gonna keep
the country closed.
I'm not gonna oversee the
funeral of the greatest country
and economy in the
history of the world.
And he meekly goes
back and says,
look, I'm just here to
give medical advice.
I'm just a doctor.
You're the president.
Your job is to account
for all the other factors.
And he backed off
pretty quickly there.
And so again, interesting
guy to work with.
He was very pleasant.
We had a good working
relationship together,
but very politically
calculating and savvy,
and wasn't always on our team.
- Did you feel that from
the agencies in general,
that the CDC or the NIH or
whoever else you worked with,
that generally they
weren't gonna be staffed
with Trump people, so there
was an odd incentive structure?
They knew an
election was coming.
- Yes and no.
Look, so Dr. Collins
at NIH, I thought
was very professional,
very knowledgeable,
always doing well.
We had a couple of
tensions with him
about getting EUAs,
because they were trying
to preserve perfect science.
But we're saying, like
saying convalescent plasma
was an issue where we
got killed in the paper
because we were pushing to say
this is something that's
been around for 100 years.
We have a study that's
showing that it's working.
Get it out there, let
doctors make the decision
if they want it or not, but
they're saying the study,
which was done by the
Mayo Clinic, I think,
or Cleveland Clinic,
wasn't done pristinely.
I said, look, this is war time.
If it's looking good, let
people make their decisions.
It's not gonna kill people.
And that was where we had some
fights with the scientists.
The CDC was an absolute
barn fire mess.
There was one fight I
had with them where,
and again, I backed off
quickly because I'm saying,
okay, how is this gonna
look on the front page
of the New York Times,
and I'm screaming
at the head of the CDC.
But they basically were
saying this 14 days rule,
and I said, okay, they're
telling our people
they have to
quarantine for 14 days.
I said, where does
that come from?
Well, we have a study.
She said, I'll
bring you the study.
So that night, again, I
was on two hours of sleep,
but I read through the study.
And I'm seeing that it's
like a study of 182 people,
of which they know 140
of them got the disease.
The average time from
contracting the disease
to showing symptoms
was 5.1 days,
and because the sample
size was so small,
they used two
standard deviations
and told the whole
world they had to spend
14 days in quarantine.
- [Dave] Wow.
- I'm saying, wait,
we're screwing up
the entire global economy off
the sample size of 140 people.
So my point is like
a lot of the things
they were saying in the name
of science were not scientific.
You know, we tried to be nimble,
and at first we trusted
all these people
because what the
hell do we know?
These were the experts
on infectious diseases.
But I think over time
we became more convinced
that we had to be pragmatic
about these things
and take their guidance
and their perspective,
but weigh it accordingly,
knowing that they were
a lot of academics who
weren't very operational.
Somebody like Dr. Birx
was actually quite helpful
because she'd been
on the front lines
in a lot of these different
countries in Africa.
So when it came to problems,
she knew operationally
how to solve them, and again,
I thought she was a
very useful voice.
I learned a lot from her.
But it was a very
complicated time to be in.
An amazing
experience, and again,
I do think the work
that President Trump did
saved a ton of lives, and I
think if you would have had
a normal politician there
instead of an outsider,
somebody who had a
results mentality,
the outcomes would have been
significantly different.
- Well maybe this
is a silly question,
but do you think, had
the Democrats, media,
some of the organizations,
CDC, et cetera,
had they all been willing
to work with Trump
a little bit more, do
you think we could be
in some real golden
age right now,
that so many of the things
that we see with the economy,
supply chain, just all the
nonsense that we're seeing,
disaster in Afghanistan,
that we really did have
a chance to fix so much?
You mentioned before
the peace deals,
there was a whole bunch
coming right there.
Do you think that had
he, he was willing
to work with people, right?
- Very much so.
Look, I think that
one of the things
I try to be very
honest about in my book
is that I had certain
biases coming in,
and my biases changed.
But we all have biases.
I think that the media
today, in particular,
is not really honest
about their biases,
and I don't think
people are as liberated,
where they still feel like
playing to the standard
of the media is the
appropriate standard
by which to try to
conduct your conduct.
And ultimately we became
liberated and said,
okay, let's just do
what we think is right.
But I do think a lot of these
people in these agencies
tried to play to the media,
and the media was rewarding
anyone who was in
opposition to Trump.
So that was kind of the
general playing field.
Again, not right or wrong,
it's just the reality
of what it was.
I think from a pure policy
point of view, like I said,
I think I'm more of a
centrist, more of a pragmatist
in terms of how I think
about these things.
A lot of President Trump's
policies I thought were spot on.
Like trade, there was
a big debate on trade.
Bringing our manufacturing
jobs back to America
was something that was anti,
I mean, Paul Ryan
was pissed at us
and saying you're never gonna
get a USMCA trade deal done.
But my mentor on that
was Bob Lighthizer who,
by the way, is I think the
best character in this book.
People have come away
saying that they really want
to meet Bob, and he really was
a mentor and a great friend,
and hysterically funny.
And I write about what it
was like working with him.
But trade was an issue.
You know, immigration, right?
So a lot of my friends
in New York would say,
well, the wall is
xenophobic and racist.
And I'd say, okay, well
maybe that's what they feel,
but then you get down
there and you're like,
well, it's just like
a sovereignty issue.
And then I talked to
the border agents.
Every mile of wall you put
up, we can do more and more.
And I write about actually
how we got the wall built,
because that became a
symbol of Trump's success.
And so the Democrats, and
even, I mean, Steve Bannon,
John Kelly, they were
supposed to get it done
for the first two years.
Both failed.
Trump asked me to get it done.
I write about how we
found the $11 billion
and I worked with Stephen
Miller, Pat Cipollone,
Chad Wolf, Mark Morgan,
a whole group of people,
Russ Volt, to figure out
how do we get the money,
and then how do we get
it implemented and built?
And so even on immigration.
I think the merit-based
immigration system
he was working on is something
that would have kept wages
in America rising, brought
a lot of GDP creators
to our country.
People said he was
against immigrants,
but he was wanting people to
come to our country legally
and make America
a vacuum cleaner
of all the best and
brightest in this world
so that they will continue
to take our country
to the next level.
So I thought his policies
were really excellent.
And to your question
specifically,
I do give examples in the
book of Kim Kardashian
or Van Jones, people who were
not naturally with Trump,
coming to the White House on
an issue they cared about.
Both of them took a lot of grief
from people in the
liberal circles.
I think Van was getting
called an Uncle Tom
for coming and
working with Trump.
But Van did something
that they didn't do.
I mean, he had John Lewis
criticizing him for doing it,
but meanwhile we got the
biggest criminal justice reform
and prison reform bill done
in the history of our country.
And so I think that
Trump was always,
people who would go out and
criticize him on television,
I always saw that
as virtue signaling,
and I have no patience
for virtue signaling.
But people who wanted
to get things done,
a lot of people
would work with me
behind the scenes on things.
Some things didn't get
done in those meetings.
You'd be surprised, some
people are in my office
in the White House
meeting on policies.
And Trump, any time
somebody wanted to reach out
and meet with him,
he'd hear them out.
Sometimes he would
agree, sometimes not.
But I always saw him
more as a pragmatist
than anything else.
- I think I legally
have to ask you,
so if, let's just say,
he was to run again
and you get the call again,
or Ivanka gets the call
or it's on speaker phone,
how are you gonna feel?
- Look, I think that, and
I'll tell you what I believe.
So number one with Trump, you
never know what he's gonna do,
and you never know what's
gonna happen, right?
That's the only thing that
you can say with certainty.
Number two is I do believe
that he is very bothered
by what he sees them
doing to this country.
If you think about when
he left we had peace
throughout the world, China
was on their back heel,
we even had a deal
with the Taliban
that I think would have
worked out really well,
no wars in Europe, economy
was getting ready to explode,
gas prices were low, inflation
was low, wages were rising.
- It was pretty good.
People forget, but
it was pretty good.
- 2019 was the first year in 20
that the wealth gap in our
country started to shrink,
which was amazing,
and that was because
people on the bottom
were making a lot more
because of Trumponomics.
So the policies were great.
But now these guys come
in, and number one is
the only thing that unites
them is that they hate Trump.
That's why they're raiding
him and investigating him,
and they can't stop
talking about him.
And Biden just gave a
speech all about him,
which is crazy after
he raids his home.
Again, this is
getting very close
to third world country stuff.
This is stuff that we would
be mad at a dictator for.
But his policies
were really good,
and I wished when they came
in that they would say,
do you know what, let's
just maybe talk the way
politicians are
supposed to talk,
and just keep all
of Trump's policies,
and I think they
could have gone down
as an incredible administration.
But instead they've
chosen to do the opposite,
and I think for him, he knows
that he could fix things
really quickly, and that's
what I think is pushing him
to want to do something, and
whether he makes a decision,
that'll be up to him.
But we'll see what
happens with that.
- So let's finish up
with something that's
not Trump related
and not directly DC
related or anything else,
but when I moved
down to Florida,
when we moved down in December,
I get an email from you,
and it basically says, hey,
heard you're down here in Miami.
Let's get together.
Now we've become friendly and
had dinner a couple of times,
and you said something to me
the first time that we met
that has really
rung true with me,
which is you said
something to the effect,
and maybe you could, I'll
slightly butcher the quote
and then you can fix it, but I
think you said something like
if America is to succeed,
it starts here in Miami,
something to that effect, that
something is happening here
in Miami, and more
broadly, Florida,
that is the map for the
rest of the country.
Now, clearly I believe that.
You know how much
we're loving it here.
I just opened these
offices and this studio.
It's so flourishing here.
What should people know about
what's going on down here?
And did you guys always think
you were gonna come down here
once DC was done?
Was it immediate?
Let's go down to
Florida and Miami?
How did you even end up here?
- It was very last minute.
First of all, I was very
glad when I saw you move down
because you were a
voice that I followed
when I was in the White House,
and I know we'd
missed each other
at one of the parties
in the White House.
And when I saw you come
down, I said this is great,
because Florida
people are forming,
it's a place where
everyone's helping everyone.
And so the decision
was like this, right.
We're figuring out
what we want to do.
We traveled the whole
country, so we'd seen
all these different places.
So we'd identified maybe
two or three cities
that we thought could be
really exciting places to go.
New York was out of the
question at the time
because it was
basically like Pompei.
It was closed down, the
restaurants were closed,
the school were closed, none
of our friends were there.
Everyone had either gone
to the Hamptons or Florida,
or some people living in Aspen.
And we basically said, you know,
this doesn't feel
like the place to go.
So we said, Florida
we honed in on.
I joked with Ivanka.
I said, look, I know we're
about 30 years ahead of schedule
because most old people
end up here anyway.
(Dave speaks in
foreign language)
Exactly.
But it felt like a place that
had the energy of the future.
And so we come down
here, and we said,
look, if we don't like it,
we'll put the kids in school,
it has a very nice
Jewish community,
then we'll go back to
New York in the fall.
We came down and we
just fell in love.
I mean, first of all,
the weather's great,
the energy's great.
What really surprised us,
though, was the people.
So right now you have people
from LA, San Francisco,
Chicago, New York coming down.
But you have an original
crop of Miamians
who are also phenomenal.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Everyone's coming together.
When we were coming
up in New York,
it felt like a city
that had become great.
Over the previous decades,
people had fought to make it.
Here you have people
coming together
trying to create a great city.
They're all very
invested in doing things
civically, socially.
We've made a ton of
amazing new friends.
I've call it sometimes it's
like freshman year of college
where everyone's creating
new friend groups,
trying new hobbies.
When you go to, with your
kids, you have activities,
taking them fishing,
taking them boating.
So it's just a very
creative place.
Now, what I find is
everyone comes through.
So what I loved in Washington
was that the local community
were like jackals because
it's a one industry town,
but you always had
very interesting people
from business, from
intellectual, just
passing through
trying to influence in one way.
Here you have an
amazing community,
but you also have a lot
of people coming through.
And then what I find is that
it's a very tolerant place,
and that you can be
at dinner with people
very liberal, very conservative.
Everyone wants to
learn from each other,
and I find that it's
a place where people
don't take themselves
too seriously.
Everyone's doing
interesting things,
everyone has
interesting stories,
and the lifestyle's amazing.
So that's been our
experience so far.
I know that you're
also converted as well.
- There is nothing that I
can possibly say right now
that my audience has not
heard me say about Florida.
- Did I repeat a
lot of your talk?
- It was pretty much, yeah,
it's pretty good here.
That's the point.
And it must feel kind of
refreshing for you guys
in that regard, that
you're sort of out
of the political thing, and
then you get to build something
in a place that seems to
represent some of the ideas
you were trying to get
across to the country.
- Yeah, we don't miss it.
And I will say too,
Florida, and again,
it's been interesting
that it's becoming
this big Republican
epicenter now,
the free state of Florida.
But it feels like it's more of
a freedom driven Republican,
a no judgment.
I think a lot of the
future of what I think
conservatism can be.
And again, the one
thing I'll say too,
I'm very hesitant to
use labels, right?
I learned that we're
basically a two party country
right now, but Democrats
and Republicans,
they're each a
collection of tribes
more than they're like
ubiquitous parties.
But I feel like here in Florida,
it's just a lot of people
doing creative things,
and a lot of fun people.
So it's been a lot of fun
to be a part of it so far.
- Well, thank you for coming
down to our Locals studio
here in Miami.
You are the first guest
in the Locals studio.
- You were actually the first
guest in the Locals studio.
- Technically I was the
first guest in my own studio.
- Yeah, I watched that one.
- Good to see you, my man.
- Thank you, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.